E
[Aplausos]
aí galera ser pai é
e antes de eu falar que você Pai eu
quero
a começar pelo começo para mim começar
pelo começo vindo aonde ouvir com
16 anos ter perdido a minha mãe já
assumi do valor idade sendo de menor
trabalhando segurando um peso de uma
família que era eu e meus dois irmãos e
com a falta de ter um pai por mais que
eu tive meu tio que criou a gente que eu
chamo ele de pai até hoje a gente sente
falta né a gente acredita que o abraço
mais forte quando você não tem sua mãe
quando você tem seu pai eu convivi com
essa dependência de ter um pai e viver
sem um pai paterno sangue mas tive
muitas pessoas que eu primieira falando
você é meu pai partir de hoje
e eu encontrei com o refúgio funk a
música vem da onde eu vim chegar onde eu
cheguei
a caminhar aprender o que é se tornar
alguém sozinho
tomando os capas na rua entendendo o que
é certo ou errado sem um pai presente
para tirar no Concelho
e até que dia eu me tornei o Mc kekel
já começou brincando cantando funk mas
as pessoas ouvirem até preciso que não
gostavam mas chegou um dia aqui a
internet me aceitou como Mc kekel e ali
menino novo solteiros fizeram
aprendi muito muito muito muito até o
dia que eu casei
o tipo de tem a melhor experiência da
minha vida de tornar um pai
e eu tive minha filha mais velha que a
Heloísa quando eu tiver eu entendi uma
coisa muito forte
Oi Fer Paes em ter um pai muita Molecada
da minha idade acho que tem filho a vida
parar por ali ou Vira de ponta cabeça
para mim ter uma filha foi ver começo Eu
Nasci de Novo
eu comecei a entender o porquê muitas
coisas podem acontecer quando a gente é
muito novo
eu achei que você desse lado aí mas não
entender um pouco da história que eu vou
contar para vocês e a mãe me criou
somente ela ela era a famosa Pereirão
fazer tudo ela era minha mãe também é
meu pai era meu confidente minha amiga
amigo também ela Simple o tudo que ela
queria fazer
e tem por eu seu filho do meio
o homem e a tia minha irmã KL são muito
difícil vai criar a gente nossos pais
que você imagina você tem que vamos
fazer na sua casa sua mãe ter que
trabalhar e você criança você com desejo
com vontade ou às vezes você sendo o
filho homem querendo ter alguém para te
ensinar o que é ser homem o que é sim
pouco um homem
Oi e um dia
toda aquelas estrutura se mexer
eu aprendi um torno disso que pai
e estamos nesse chamada de pai acho que
a maior conversa entre um homem a ser
chamado de amigo você desabafar Vontade
sempre em Barreira para estar perto de
você e com a minhas filhas eu comecei
aprender isso hoje eu entendo que o
passado me fez por lá que eu sou hoje o
presente muitas vezes só o lado da
câmera da televisão mas o lado de fora
da câmera presente a história do SUS
pode ser igual a minha se você se acha
como o pai que quer chegar perto do seu
filho Jesus não se sente presente sabe
que não é presente quer se tornar
presente seja apresente como um amigo e
até a hora que pode sair sozinho pai eu
te amo isso eu aprendi tendo o pai hoje
eu olhei para minhas filhas eu vejo elas
como
se fosse um herói para elas é a
preencher meu pai sim ser sem ter meu
pai tô sem imagina imagina agora com 26
anos sem ter minha mãe eu tenho que
olhar na casa do meu pai hoje
tu sabe que eu aprendi pois
a perdoar
e quando você aprende a perdoar você
entende o que é amar alguém
umas férias você não tipo mais que
aconteceu no passado que poderia
corrigir seria ido hoje no presente que
pode corrigir seus ossos
então se você tem a mesma história de
vida que a minha não é conselho ele
vence
e a gente fala que me ama só e que pai é
aquele que cria
É mas o pai de sangue ela nunca vai
deixar de ser a partir do momento que
ele quer
ser perdoado ele tem que tornar seu
amigo mesmo sempre chamado de pai isso
aqui é o senhor de hoje mas das férias
e se um beijo mesmo hospital já sei
passa a hora que eu fico pensando
eu vou desce novamente Ver o seu filho
também os que deram exame da sua cara
falando que eu cansei ninguém minhas
filhas também causa que a vó foi forte
expectorar escola vou falar da minha
irmã quer sair o sofá e a criança
mexendo aprender e nada foi vão
chorar
chorar para quem não foi em vão
obrigado por tudo Conceição
a chorar para que se arrepender bota
pega o homem lá de cima que o dia você
vai vencer chorar para que não foi igual
obrigado por tudo para ativar Conceição
o seu filho também os que deram risada
da sua cara falando que eu não achei
ninguém
E aí